je suis allé à la rencontre de quelques
éducateurs et éducatrices et des jeunes
et des adultes entre 12 et 40 ans à
Paris Porte de vre dans le 14e et place
des fêtes dans le 19e et aussi le 93 à
sainttoouin et à épin sur
scne des éducateurs se trouve au cœur de
la prévention de l'enfance ils aident
les jeunes en difficultés et créent des
liens dire un simple bonjour être
toujours présent dans les quartiers dans
la rue dans le local des éducateurs dans
les
familles il les accompagne sur toutes
sortes de situations souvent
instables ils sont là dans les endroits
où parfois il n'y a plus
personne un lien sur le temps qui
construit la relation ou pas mais qui
laisse une présence de confiance sur le
trajet des
jeunes bon ben bon foot les garçon merci
entraînez-vous bien tu as des nouvelles
toi pour ta détection ouais j'ai mais je
pas faire
pourquoi alors qu'il est blessé d'où tu
es blessé qu'est-ce que t'
fait mal au genou tu as mal au genoux un
coup pendant le foot ça t'appelle
endroit o tu mal et est-ce que tu l'as
immobilisé est-ce que tu as mis de la
pommode est-ce que tu as fait ce qu'il
fallait la pom moi je te conseille quand
même aller voir un médecin boubou prends
soin de toi c'est important d'accord
allez bon foot les garçons
salut je suis arrivé ici avec encore une
grande proximité d'âge au final avec les
jeunes qu'on accomagne 12 21 après on
sait que au final la Prévention
Spécialisée on dit pas un jeune à 21 ans
maintenant tu te démerdes donc j' avais
des jeunes de 24 de 25 de de 30 ans
quand je suis arrivé le premier soir où
je me suis retrouvver tout seul dans le
local avec des grands qui qui me
testaient un peu qui me qui me
bousculaient voir comment je réagissais
parce que j'étais que je tenais la route
tout ça je me suis dit
waouh c'est pas un boulot
facile et en fait c'est par les actes
qu'on qu'on crée la relation de
confiance j'ai un souvenir dans ce
bureau justement mon premier été donc je
suis arrivée en février je me suis
retrouvé toute seule un long moment
parce que mes collègues étaient en
vacances en était que trois à ce
moment-là et des grands qui sont venus
des grands de mon âge de 25 ans ils
étaient quatre ils sont posés dans ce
bureau trois et en fait ils ont sorti un
couteau et ils m'ont demandé de mettre
la main comme ça et qu'il fasse tac tac
tac tac tac tac donc j'ai refusé mais ça
a été compliqué pour moi ils m'ont posé
des questions sur ma sexualité donc je
leur ai répondu de la sexualité en
général voilà qu'est-ce que enfin un
orgasme féminin enfin voilà mais c'est
cétait assez déconcertant pour moi j'ai
tenu je su bien tenu et quand ils sont
sortis je me vois en fait transpirer
j'en pouvais plus j'ai même les larmes
qui sont monté parce que j'ai eu peur en
fait j'ai eu peur pour moi je me suis
dit mais qu'est-ce qu'ils vont me faire
avec leur couteau là des grands qui
sortaient de prison enfin voilà c'est
reparlé au grand et il se rappelle plus
il dis non c'est pas V on tuas pas fait
ça carreau quand même je si si on m'
fait ça une mais tu as eu peur je fa
moment que j'ai eu peur et je leururis
dit j'ai cru peut-être me violer ENF
j'ai eu peur les garçons
vous rendez pas compte vous me sortez un
couteau il y en a qui venit de sortir de
prison enfin je je vous connaissais pas
plus que ça donc oui j'ai eu peur et ils
m'ont dit mais tu sais on t'a testé je
pense à ce momentl cétait pour voir si
tu tenais et en fait il y a vraiment
tout ce truc de test aussi qui est
vachement important en prévention
spécialisée surtout nous en tant que
femme tout ce qui va être la drague ils
vont tester ils vont
mettre ton CV làdessus s'il te plaît
j'ai envoyé mais je sais pas si c'est
vraiment parti ou pas mais c'est pas un
CV ça adress mail je veux dire ça si
si tu as beaucoup d'amis oui beaucoup
beaucoup dans le quartier on connait
plein presque tout le monde et tout le
monde te connaît aussi oui et tout le
monde connaît feuvard euh presque
qu'est-ce qu'on dit des éducateurs tes
copains tout ça tout le monde ils disent
que ça serait bien si sincriver mais le
problème c'est que des fois ils sont
occupés pendant la semaine et tu pas les
voir dans le local
oui à chaque fois que je passes par là
je vois que c'estouvert je dis bonjour
je me souviens de toi disant venir voir
les éducateurs c'est bien mais ça ne
durera pas toute la
vie tu aimerais que ça dure toute la vie
oui tu sais pourquoi parce que c'est
génial
si je pourrais m'occuper sans X mais
quand même ça ça me rendrait triste un
peu de d'être sans eu parce que quand
même des fois on passe des bons moments
même si je leur parle pas d'un d'un truc
d'organisation on dit faire mes devoirs
même je on peut venir ici on fait des
jus de société on un petit bûé ou je
sais pas des trucs comme ça et ça ça me
rend
oui ouais oui oui je l'ai entendu cy
cyber harcèlement on a le cyber
harcèlement donc ça c'est le harcèlement
qui se fait sur les réseaux les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que ça se fait beaucoup
ça oui oui et face à une personne qui
subit du harcèlement vous pouvez en
parler à une personne de confiance ça
peut être qui cette personne de
confiance est-ce que ça peut être les
parents
ça peut être les parents un professeur
surveillance CPE psychologue infirmière
est-ce que y a il peut avoir d'autres
adultes de confiance à qui on peut en
parler en fait madame je sais pas ce que
ah ça peut être qui mais nous on est qui
les prof on n pas des profes
pas on n pas des mais qu'est-ce qu'il
racontent vous adult on est des adultes
oui on pe commencer par là non c'est la
ré des
directrice des
prétendantes donc vous pouvez en parler
à des éducateurs d'accord il faut savoir
que par exemple un éducateur comme un
psychologue comme une infirmière comme
un assistante social sont soumis au
secret professionnel c'est-à-dire vous
pouvez nous confier des choses et nous
on va pas aller le répéter à vos parents
sauf bien sûr il y a des conditions si
on estime que vous êtes en danger oui on
sera amené à en parler à vos parents
mais nous sommes soumis au secret
professionnel je suis jamais tombée sur
un jeune qui dit ça m'intéresse pas des
fois ils on pas trop le dire oui je
passe bientôt bon au moins il sait où
nous trouver
euh après des fois ça ça prendre du
temps il y a je sais qu'il y a des
jeunes qui ont été accompagnés 5 ans
après enfin le principal c'est qu'il
nous est repéré en tant que personne
ressource et si un jour il estime qu'il
a besoin de nous solliciter il sait où
nous trouver après c'est pour ça que
c'est important de créer du lien parce
que quand le lien manque on a du mal à
échanger avec les jeunes et c'est
réciproque et du coup c'est pour pour ça
que c'est important de consolider de
renforcer ce lien là qui est un lien
d'échange de confiance mutuelle et le
plus difficile je dirais c'est au moment
où peut-être j'ai du mal à comprendre ce
qu'un jeune veut me dire après ça se
travaille sur la durée et c'est pas
grave on le formule autrement B des fois
il faut se répéter faut faire preuve de
patience'est-ce que j'ai dit qu'est-ce
que j'ai dit les cours ont déjà
commencé il le jeune il en a marre parce
que à l'école tout le monde lui dit ça
il rentre chez lui ses parents lui
disent ça et puis moi quand il avec moi
bah sans forcément faire la part des
choses je lu dis la même chose B ça pe
pas marcher et moi quel moyen j'ai pour
me faire comprendre
autrement
le le moyen le plus efficace c'est le
temps
les enseignants eux ils crient trop et
moi j'en ai marre de l'école parce que
c'est trop nul parce que ça me saoule
après ma mère elle me CRE quand j'ai des
mauvaises notes je la je la rends
énervée moi j'aime pas la rendre énervée
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de faire
tout tard moi
footballeur et moi si j'arrive pas à
percer dans le foot
si j'arrive pas à gagner des sous dans
le
foot je vais essayer d'êtrechit
ingénieur j'ai toujours dit j'ai hâte
d'avoir une carte bancaire parce qu'en
fait quand je demande des trucs à mes
parents à chaque fois il dis non non non
non non non du coup moi j'ai hâte
d'avoir une carte bancaire et j'ai hâte
de travailler comme ça j'ai beaucoup de
de kishta comme on dit comme ça je
pourrais m'acheter tous mes
plaisirs il y a une chose qui vient
juste de
t'arriver ça peut être dans le malheur
et dans le bonheur tu vas pas et tu vois
un animateur que tu aimes bien tu
l'aimes bien tu fais confiance tu lu
fais confiance tu vas lui
dire par exemple tu vas rentrer dans une
salle il vontenlever la
capuche d'abord tu as pas le droit de
ils vont pas te laisser dire des gros
mots plein de
choses la
vie moi j'ai trois
projets d'abord mon plan a rappeur si ça
marche pas j'ai un plan B c'est acteur
si ça marche pas plan C boxeur je pense
que ce qu'il a voulu dire en tout cas
par rapport à la discussion qu'on a eu
c'était parler déjà de la de l'avenir et
être capable de se projetter le fait de
voir ça chez des très jeunes déjà qui
sans même savoir ce qu'ils veulent faire
savent ce qu'ils veulent être et entre
guillemetsre du bon côté de la barrière
à ceage c'est déjà très très
important là vous êtes relou je vous
assure
vous
est des des
mendiants dans la manière où il se
présentaient à nous je savais que que
ils étaient là pour nous que ils
pouvaient nous écouter et nous aider
dans plein de domaines ma manière de
réfléchir je pense grâce à eux bah elle
a changé un peu desau maturité niveau
maturité je pense elle a changé parce
qu'avant j'étais un gamin mais là depuis
euh je me comporte un peu plus comme un
adulte et mais en vrai si je suis
content c'est mieux en fait c'est c'est
avec c'est pas avec le temps mais je
sais pas comment expliquer c'est au fur
et à mesure qu'on comprend ce qu' ce qui
ce qu'ils font leur métier ils se
mettent dans notre peau en gros et et
nous mettent à l'aise aussi les
éducateurs en fait c'est le premier
séjour qu'on fait avec eux on a proposé
de partir 3 qu jours dans le chat de feu
vert ils sont un peu fatigués du coup vu
qu'ils dorment pas trop la nuit mais ça
va ils ont pas fait trop de bruit cette
nuit donc euh forcément quand on les
entend parler on on apprend des choses
ou quand il nous parle quand on est posé
pendant des heures ici et du coup il il
s'ouvre là avec eux on travaille aussi
les gros mots le ou la façon de se
comporter quand on est en quand il y a
des éducateurs ou quand il y a d'autres
personnes et là je sens par exemple le
travail il avance au tout début il y a
un an c'était pas du tout comme ça les
les gros mots ça ça fusait dans tous les
sens ils sont dans une bulle donc en
fait ils se rendent pas compte du regard
des gens ou de ce que de ce que les gens
peuvent penser d'eux ou ils le voient
plus ils font plus attention à
ça ils grandissent aussi mais je pense
que aussi le travail qu'on a fait avec
eux
comme ça regarde tu fais ça après claque
et après tu tu coupes et après le
sens regarde tu dét tu détes après tu tu
colles ici tu colles tu colles tu ces tu
ces C tu ces tu viens ici et tu ref en
tour Mar
excellent va voir moi ce que j'ai j'ai
toujours trouvé exceptionnel chez chez
ces jeunes mais même adultes c'est cette
capacité de rebondir ils ont une espèce
de et
puis de
dédramatisation tu vois où rien n'est
grave en fait tout peut être pris à la
rigolade et même tu le vois dans leur
rapport entre eux il se chambre beaucoup
et ça c'est aussi assez culturel c'est
souvent mon discours de dire euh en fait
moi ce que je veux c'est pas que vous
deveniez quelqu'un d'autre ni que vous
me serviez la soupe en ayant l'attitude
parfaite d'un enfant sous cloche mais
c'est plutôt d'avoir déguiser votre
intelligence de sorte d'être adapté à
tout ce qui vous entoure pour pas que la
société elle vous elle vous elle vous
sorte de ces rang en disant que vous
êtes inadapté parce que là du coup euh
tu vas pas pouvoir prendre la place que
tu souhaites prendre donc l'idée c'est
que tu puisses réaliser tes rêves
prendre la place dont tu rêves en
fonction de tes compétences et que il y
a il y a rien qui est trop beau pour toi
en fait par contre faut que tu acceptes
de jouer avec les
codes j'en leur en ai pas encore parlé
mais moi dans on en a pas parler mais
moi sincèrement j'aurais bien repris les
deux mêmes ouais ça a bien
fonctionnéve un peu C je trouve que ça a
bien fonctionné en plus là c'est dans
les locaux de la Mission locale c'est
dans du coup c'est le même prestataire
tu vois j'aurais trouvé ça intéressant
de remettre les deux si vous êtes
d'accord après fallait qu'on en parle en
équipe c'est pour ça que volontairement
genre en ai pas du tout parlé encore le
premier lundi alors que moi j'étais en
vacances une semaine avant
pass les adolescents ils ont ils ont un
mouvement de vie ils sont fragiles mais
ils ont un mouvement de vie très fort
une pulsion de vie très forte et donc il
ils expriment des choses à l'état brut
quoi et à leur contact j'apprends
j'apprends sur sur effectivement qu'on
peut que c'est une période où on peut
être fragile sur tellement de points
tellement de points et que c'est
important de pouvoir les comprendre de
pouvoir leur laisser leur chance de
pouvoir les accueillir dans notre
société parce que c'est les adultes de
demain 45 secondes juste
ça je ramène ici au visage passe ta
hanche décolle le talon jambarrière
décolle le talon jambarrière regarde
comment je suis je profite tu peux me
voir effectivement pas mal de gamins euh
euh j'aime pas l'école j'aime pas
l'école euh euh je je m'ennuie euh je
suis au fond de la classe je dis je
bavarde euh je dessine euh de toute
façon j'aime pas la prof euh je sais pas
ce que j fais à l'école ça me sert à
quoi qu'est-ce que ça m' apporter plus
tard et c'est vrai que euh on on se pose
même plus la question mais là dans un
peu euh il faut que tu aille à l'école
c'est de toute façon l'école elle est
obligatoire obligatoire et pourquoi
pourquoi je suis obligé d'All l'école
pourquoi quand on adulte on obligé de
bosser pourquoi euh euh
euh il faut pas tricher pour
pourquoi pourquoi ma vie elle est
définie à l'avance va moins vite va
moins vite la qualité la qualité pas la
quantité la qualité donc l'idée c'est
aussi de les aider à se définir eux-même
en terme d'identité en terme de est-ce
que ma place elle est ici est-ce que ma
place elle est ailleurs est-ce que ma
place elle est dans les voyages est-ce
que ma place elle est auprès des autres
et on leur fait
souvent comprendre dans notre discours
que bah les armes elles passent par la
scolarité
et le système a été conçu comme ça c'est
cette importance de mot en fait où des
jeunes des fois peuvent rier d'un coup
et on le voit dans le milieu scolaire où
des fois des professeurs vont dire là tu
as été bête ou tu es bête B alors ça le
jeune là il explose et c'est vrai que ça
c'est super important là toujours
réfléchir à l'importance des mots qu'on
emploie il y a pas mal d'adolescents
quand ils ont des carences affectives
qui viennent de de l'enfant je me suis
rendu compte en les accompagnant qui ont
du mal à accepter que quelqu'un puisse
être là pour eux et ce qui est assez
enfin moi que je trouve passionnant dans
ce métier et à leur contact c'est qu' on
arrive à un moment donné et ça prend
énormément de temps avec des jeunes
comme ça après ils sont pas tous mais
qui ont des des fragilités de c'est que
il nous
demande énormément de preuv d'amour lève
ta main droite lè ta main
droiteà plus tu es relâché plus tu es en
mouvement c'est pas grave tu t'en es
rendu compte c'est bien continue lâche
pas allez lâche pas
ouais bien joué lafflexion descends un
peu plus voilà tu vois tu arrives quand
je considère que c'est réussi c'est
quand je me rends compte que
relationnellement si tu veux j'ai passé
une étape avec la personne qui fait que
la personne a réellement confiance en
moi c'est ça que je s'appelle de la
bonne fatigue c'est bien c'est comparé
au derniè sens là c'est mieux ça parce
que plus on plus on change de semaine
plus on commence à faire des trucs qu'on
apprécie mieux en plus comme tu as dit
la confiance on a fait un travail sur
nous on a on se parle on fait confiance
aux autres c'est mieux ouais c'est ça on
commence à commence à avancer c'est bien
faut qu'on continue comme ça c'est tout
les jeunes par exemple quand on les
accompagne dans une démarche ils aiment
n tenir informé de ce qu'il en est et au
fond de moi-même au fond de mon petit
cœur mais je suis tellement content pour
eux après je monte peut-être pas ce
temps là ah bah c'est bien je suis
contente pour toi mais au fond de moi
ouais je me dis petite victoire petite
victoire parce que je l' accompagnaé
j'ai su le remobiliser quand lui il se
démobilisait je l'ai jamais lâché je m
mis des petits coup de pieds aux fesses
mainant ça suffit tuarrêtes tu vas y
arriver je suis derrière toi et et quand
le jeune il arrive en disant bah tiens
regarde j'ai mon diplôme ouais bah je
suis contente je pense que peut-être que
si on avait pas été là en effet serétait
pas allé au bout parce qu'ils avaient
besoin un moment donné quelqu'un qui
croit en eux quelqu'un qui les pousse et
et souvent c'est des jeunes qu' ont pas
perdu confiance en eux mais pas loin là
il faut que je joue en premier quelle
école tu vux en première là là là to
c'est proc quelle école tu veas en
première desbout si tu as le choix ah
bah si Ferand je ferandy direct fer fend
sur mon c ok un ferend 2 il y a des
choses que je peux pas dire à ma mère
directement je passe parlera directement
et après elle peut me donner des petites
idées des petites idées qui font que
enin des conseils pas des idées plutôt
des conseil comment je peux dire à ma
mère des fois elle peut elle-même en
parler directement à ma mère elle est en
relation avec ma mère directement c'est
comme une grande personne c'est c'est
comme si c'était une personne de ma
famille à qui je faisais confiance en
fait il nous mett en confiance comme si
on avait une relation de père fils fille
mère fille c'est ça qui fait que bah à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui on écoute un peu
mieux enfin je pense qu'on a on écoute
facilement sans peurant genre on peut
pleurer devant eux quoi on aura pas de
gêne genre par exemple on va jamais y
aller dans une ferme faire des trucs
avec des animaux dire avec feux vert on
est parti par exemple on va jamais se
dire on va faire une une distribution
pour les SDF avec feux verts il n monte
vers le haut en fait la soupe on va
l'accrocher les minettes à une seule
femme alors vas-y envoie les tubet je
les mets
ici e venez pas monau là maintenant à
partir de maintenant vous ouvrez vos
yeux ouais ouais Tinqui gauche celles
qui sont à gauche regarde à gauche
celles qui sont à droite regarde à
droite et quand on voit un SDF on
s'arrête en de en speed là et on
distribue Wes Sonia wesh oh tu parles
mal oh là là CIT oh là
là bah ça va ça va oui maisf à un moment
donné c'est un budget aussi pour nous
feu vert c'est on peut pas j'aimerais
bien dans ce caslà on fait des petits
pavés de saumon on fait tout ça ça
j'entends bien les filles mais voilà il
faut faut être aussi réaliste voilà on
fait avec ce qu'on a non mais c'est quoi
ce chantage attache-toi je te
dis
attachche non toi
ou
qui ça danser tour dans le no
leleil les PA fa pas mettre
dedans va les garçons des vra tours les
gars des vrais tours arrêtez de
couper ça va attention c'est pas
grave j'ai vécu des tas de choses en
terme de suivi l'harcèlement scolaire
viol j'ai qu accompagné plein de jeunes
à bobini prison pour mineur
prison la génération peut-être un peu
moins violente mais à l'époque on a eu
des situations mais les voitures de
policiers les jeunes en masse en groupe
qui qui allit au niveau du pont ou
niveau du collège mais on a eu des
choses mais des fictions quoi mais non
aujourd'hui non en tout cas aujourd'hui
attention moi je baretardement ce confli
quartier même qu'il a aussi avec la
source les prêles pardon c'est mon
baretardement aujourd'hui il se passe
rien pa mais demain peut-être on a la
viie de rien mais c'est vrai que ça fait
un petit moment où des faits très graves
coup de marteau coup de machette ou des
trucs comme ça attention ou des choses
ici même dans ce local pour la petite
anecdote il y avait des jeunes qui
étaient scolarisés au lycée fé qui est
plus vers la source prê donc les jeunes
orgement étaient amenés à prendre les
transports en commun et à et un moment
donn il avit un conf les jeunes du cille
je cille attend dans le parc qui à côté
un jour il sont AG Mach je fait
couper j'ai rembl tous les jeunes i lo
icip C
V a et vous jouz on part unon moment pi
ça serait bien non je vous conseiller
voilà tu fais ça çaacac et comme ça ça
travail votre esprit de solidarité et de
partage d'accord on fera ça allez on y
va les
gars c'est mieux de d'aller à F que de
rester au quartier parce que au quartier
des fois il y a rien à faire tu peux tu
peux tu
peux pas tu peux avoir des problèmes
tout ça moi j'ai pas envie d'avoir ça
moivie de rester à feu vert pas faire de
conneries pas avoir de des trucs
bizarres avec la drogue tout ça parfois
même si on n'est pas dans ça à force de
traîner avec des gens qui sont comme ça
aès nous ai on va finir par le
denir faut pas faire de gâi c'est pas
juste parce que tu vas la découper la
mangue tu fais comme ça oh comme ça
comme ça après tu loues comme une fleur
voilà c'est super ça c'est comme ça que
je fais moi
aussi
regardezm tu sais quand tu épluches tu
laisses pas ton doigt làf sinon tu peux
te le
couper tiens après il y a les
ananas faut pas mettre il n'y a que les
faiblesses qui pleurent il n a que les
faibl que les faibles qui pleure les
faibles ben non il y a pas que les
faibles qui pleur moi je dis non par
exemple si quelqu'un de dur bah il peut
pleurer pour un décès ou un truc comme
ça mais ça veut pas dire qu'il est
faible enfin si
non oh là là mais est-ce que pleurer
c'est forcément une preuve de faiblesse
non ma mère elle va me dire un truc je
veis pleurer genre ça se fait pas tout
ça après exemple il va dire pourquoi tu
pleures c'est pour les faibles et tout
du coup après j'arrête de pleurer ah
donc ça t'aide ouais parce que c'est sa
manière le fait de te le dire comme ça
c'est sa manière de te réconforter ou et
ça t'aide non non enfin genre je me dis
j'arrête de pleurer mais sinon bah j'ai
appris les avis des autres comme quoi
mon avis peut-être peut être négatif
genre j'ai su contrôler mes avis et
avoir les autres avis des gens et tu te
donnes un autre avis et c'est ça qui te
fait le fait de tu peux avoir d'autres
avis tu tu peux te dire que comme quoi
tu avais pas raison quoi et tu tu
réfléchis en fait dans ta tête ça nous
aide ça nous fait avancer et ça m par
exemple
avoir par exemple une autre mentalité
e on y va vous commencez à monter la
direct et puis les autres on va
attendre
une fiction pour moi c'est pas juste une
fiction ça peut être la réalité on sait
très bien il suffit que tu sois au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment tu
peux terminer comme le jeune homme dans
le film et moi c'est ce qui m'inquiète
aussi c'est la par rapport au quartier
je parle de superement B j'espère qu'un
jour on arrivera pas là mais pour ça il
faudra avecinttelligence moi mon
objectif avec vous l'influence que je
peux avoir avec vous c'est de vous tirer
vers l'au vous passer des
messages parce que malheureusement ça
dura pas toute la vie qu après vous es
prendre votre envol vous êtes des
adultes et des hommes et je l'espère
pour vous de bons gars et vous l'êtes
déjà donc tout ce qui vous peut vous
tirer vers le bas conflit de quartier
vas-y va faire le gay va faire le le gay
quand je dis le G c'està dire gateur
dans le quartier pour pour le pour le
trafic tout ça éloignez-vous de tout ça
les gars d'accord jamaisans je sais que
c'est plus simple c'est plus facile à
dire qu'à faire attention moi je peux te
dire j'en ai vu dans le quartier qu'
l'ont fait donc et des gars comme vous
he c'estàd sans problème intelligent qui
après on a tous des problèmes attention
mais qui était pas fait pour ça mais ils
l'ont fait par voilà par manque de
moyens ou parce qu'ils avent pas
forcément du travail et tout donc faites
attention à ça d'accord fa attention à
to junior par contre parle à papa et
maman très important tout de suite ok
Idris pareil Denis fais attention à toi
non ma elle s déjà elle s déjà c'est
quoi le oui mais tu lui tu parles du
séjour s'il te plaît d'accord de toute
façon je vais donner toutes les infos
via WhatsApp et tout ok quand on part en
séjour c'est tout de suite ils veulent
mettre leur musique en fait alors je je
leur dis ok je vais mettre bon musique
mais je mets les miennes d'abord là
c'est non non tu vas pas nous mettre tes
vieilles musiques et tout je si si je
mets mes musiquees on fait un échange
donc là c'est assez marrant et du coup
euh une fois on a fait un séjour avec
bah un groupe mixte mais on avait
retrouvé des jeunes filles qui avaient
déjà fait un séjour avec moi il m'ont
dit tu vas nous remettre du Piaf j'ai
bah tu as retenu le nom déjà et ça c'est
assez donc on échange aussi donc il nous
il nous apporte beaucoup de choses aussi
et on leur apporte beaucoup aussi c'est
le but aussi de leur apporter et le but
des séjours aussi c'est de travailler
aussi euh
bah enfin c'est toujours court les
séjours en même temps ce qui m'énerve
c'est qu'elle
regarde après elle boit sont pas aveugle
maisont pas mais elles vont dire c'est
toujours pareil en fait vont regarder
une fois deux fois pu vont dire c'est
toujours pareil la SER c'est toujours
pareil c'est bon on a
ch moi je sens plus mes pieds n serer je
vais arrêter tu vas tu fais une pause
j'appelle Karima
là et les filles rangez vos portables
pendant qu'on va la fromagerie sanéire
vous aurez le temps tac tac tac rangez
vos
téléphones
c'est pas parce que une personne elle
veut faire un truc elle laisse les 5 cou
de personnees ne pas vouloir faire et la
personne a fait on lui dit non on veut
pas faire mais elle veut dans ces CASL
on a qu'à rester à la maison elle fait
ça un autre jour elle vient un autre
weekend elle ramène son fromage a S
forcé ou voilà c'est là c'estis vraiment
c'est force en fait m'a dégoûté du
fromage voilà et du lait parce que les
vaches ell sont hyper sales les lavent
jamais
ouais c'est un truc dans tous les cas
qu'on voulait pas
faire mais bon c'est fait c'est
fait tu as fait beaucoup la tête Lina
aujourd'hui vraiment j'ai vraiment
l'impression que cette visite là c'était
une torture pour toi que je t'ai forcé
donc dis exprime-toi Lina c'est le
moment moi je voulais pas partir dans
tous les cas oui je on a on avait tous
compris on aurait fait quoi euh les
autres il partent visiter la fromagerie
j'aurais fait quoi je te'aurais laissé
mais on nous quatre on n' pas voulu y
aller pourquoi quand on a préparé la
journée hier mais pas dit ça mais même
dit non on a dit c'est chouette même si
on fait la traite des vaches je vous ai
même dit oui si on fait la traite des
vaches je vous ai dit que c'est vous
aurez fait comment si on faisait la
traite des vaches vous vous aurez fait
comment ah oua dans tous les cas si
j'aurais vu que les vaches seront comme
ça je les aurais même pas touché j'étais
pas très contente parce que à un moment
donné un séjour aussi c'est aussi du ski
vous êtes fait plaisir vous avez fait de
l'alluge mais aussi moi j tiens auss
cette partie
culturelle ils vont parler de leur
famille ils vont parler de difficultés
parler de c'est voilà il y a des choses
des fois difficile à entendre aussi donc
il y a des révélations des fois comme ça
là des fois on n'est pas toujours prêt
voilà donc du coup euh attention à bien
écouter pour reprendre ça
après
avec les mon j'ai trouvé plein des trucs
en fait des trucs vraiment sincères et
du coup elle avait le côté professionnel
mais
plus dans la vie réelle en vrai
elle donne des conseils elle a des
façons pour parler aux jeunes et elle
m'a montré comment comment elle la vit
en vrai des fois même quand j'étais des
fois dans les difficultés et tout ça
même le soir tard elle est là me répond
et après ces réponses c'est bien c'est
doux c'est compréhensive c'est c'est des
mots qui rentre vraiment dans la tête
c'est pas comme n'importe qui que quand
je le raconte c'est pas la même
chose et moi quand je le vois le comment
elle est Clémence j'aimerais bien avir
une vie commme en fait vraiment dans le
sens comment elle présente comment elle
parle comment ses manières et tout ça
vraiment bah cette séence c'était pas
comme la
première mais elle m'a appris des choses
par contre c'est pour ça que j'aime bien
te laisser aussi réfléchir et pas tout
de suite débriefer et parce que ça
s'inffuse et dans ton corps ça s'infuse
aussi comme une infus
à la
canelle je l'aime trop vraiment malgré
cétait j'étais chiante avec elle alors
moi dans mes formations on en a jamais
parlé hein bien sûr il est pas question
d'amour il est question de transfert
alors le transfert quand même c'est une
grande question d'amour mais rarement on
va t'en parler en ces termeslà parce que
c'est comme un gros mot lâché quoi comme
une bombe où on parle d'émotion d'affect
et non surtout pas et du coup c'est
c'est quand même fou parce que tu
arrives avec tout un tas de bagages en
tant qu'éduc et puis on t'a jamais parlé
de l'essentiel tu vois et et c'est c'est
j'ai l'impression un peu comme dans
l'éducation avec les enfants ou ou par
exemple la sexualité et on en parle
jamais on en parle qu'en terme de
maladie en terme de prévention des
maladies et de la grossesse
éventuellement et puis et puis fin de
l'histoire
ça tombe bien toi ça y est as eu ta pay
ou vas-y tu l'as eu ta pay ou mais
tomber mais tu l'as eu ou c'est c'est
bon tuas pu te faire un petit
resto ah c'est
bienur plutôt que le resto tu passes
quand à me voir es là demain
quelun 15h tu veux tu passes vers 15h30
16h mes grand max moi à 17h je suis
parti vasy ça je pass à 15h30 15h30 et
comme ça je t' dans les démarches vas-y
on fait comme
ça je te le dis pour toi après on va te
tailler
après mon but à moi c'est pas d'agir
forcément sur une situation marginale
que ou que moi j'estime marginal déjà
et pour qui pour qui pour moi pour euh
pour pour l'emploi pour la sécurité de
l'arrondissement pour
euh il y a des jeunes qui font des
choix qui assument leur choix qui savent
euh qu'il y aura dans cette direction
une casse prison à un moment donné
euh et qui sont pas prêts à à changer
est-ce que un jour ils auront une
rencontre amoureuse et ils décideront de
s'investir davantage dans leur rencontre
amoureuse que euh auprès de leur groupe
de pères dans des dans des dans des
codes de la rue
euh ils seront ils seront décisionnaires
je c'est pas toi qui va amener ce
changement peut-être peut-être j'en sais
rien j'en sais rien mes paroles peuvent
avoir écho dans son dans son esprit sans
même que je le sache sans même que lui
le ou elle le sache quand tu vas voir en
détention par exemple c'est c'est un
exemple un jeune tu vas le voir à un
moment donné où il est dans une
fragilité extrême et quand tu vas faire
ce mouvement là alors que tu es pas de
la famille que tu d'aller les voir et de
leur montrer par ton regard que pas que
toi tu es pas la justice donc mais que
tu es encore là pour eux tu es encore là
pour les écouter pour parler avec eux
parce que tu les apprécies
et ben là tu tu et moi pour moi c'est
vraiment le rôle de l'éducateur de
prévention parce que parce que nous on a
un rôle à jouer là-dessus c'est que nous
on peut
aller aux interstices aux endroits où où
il y a plus grand
monde
sans feu vert sans Rachid AAT tout
romain en tout cas l'équipe révbal après
je pas fa en entier mais l'équipe qui
nous a suivi je pense pas que
aujourd'hui je serai en formation en
prison ou en train de faire des bêtises
encore et là maintenant tu fais quoi là
en ce moment je suis en formation en
alternance avec la RATP pour devenir
conducteur de bus ils veulent pas nous
nous décevoir et ils savent qu'on va pas
les juger mais ils veulent qu'on garde
une image positive deur personne et ça
c'est normal et ça c'est humain mais et
puis bah faut prendre le temps donc moi
j'ai pas de voilà j'ai pas besoin de
tout savoir donc ça m'intéresse pas du
tout mais c'est vraiment ouais les
accompagner ils savent que qu'on est
quand même des des professionnels et
donc du coup quand même on a on a un œil
assez aiguisé de de qui fait quoi et
puis du coup on sera toujours là pour
eux on n pas là pour juger qui que ce
soit on est là pour
accompagner gager le maillot il est non
tu connais c'est d'abord on chauffe un
peu on chauffe un peu on chauffe un peu
qu'il faut accepter aussi le raide parce
que par exemple j'ai certains amis à moi
ou certains qui qui veulent pas de
l'aide à ver quand il croisent fe vert
bonjour au revoir mais sinon ils ont Ren
à voir avec feu vert c'est quand tu as
grandi quand on a cet âge là qu'on se
dit ah ouais ils on vraiment voulu nous
aider c'est malgré qu'on voulait pas ils
ont forcé vraiment c'est limite ils
voulent plus qu'on avance que
nous-mêmeès qu'ils ont l'amour de leurs
parents confiance de leurs parents ils
ont des discours bienveillants de la
part des parents je sais que même s'ils
sont dans une situation de
précarité ils auront de la ressource
pour
après mais s'il y a pas ce minimum
là d'amour de confiance et de discours
positif ça va être
compliqué
c'est voyez comment c'est mon père
limite limite c'est comme mon
père
2 m 2 m avec moi au collège il mange
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup c'est mon
gars quand même donc voilà ça c'est mes
frérot ça j'ai fait mon collège avec eux
et voilà voyez un ballon ça nous suffit
pour jouer et être heureux en tout cas
il sont là ça c'est mon gar rappeur
flèche
montante tu vois ce que je veux dire
voilà je en
19e regarde là tu es sur place des fr il
y a de tout et il y a de rien mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que on est tous là et
on s'en sort tous de la même manière tu
vois je suis c'est car c'est pas
je tu
montes je me suis vraiment vraiment
amusé avec vraiment je on a voyagé mes
premiers voyages sont on était fait avec
feu vert tu vois on partait dans dans le
sud dans le Nord mais c'était toujours
des voyages avec quand même cet aspect
de de faire quelque chose en retour
parce que quand on partait en voyage
c'était pas un voyage on sac coulait tu
vois on partait on ramassait des des
feuilles on travailler quoi tu vois il
nous apprenait déjà à travailler travail
mérite salaire j'étais en en pro
mécanique j'ai fait de la Pro
électronique ça m'intéressait pas tu
vois et il y avait feu vert tu vois et
je m'en souviens tu sais c'était une
dame qui s'appelait Virginie maintenant
je crois qu' elle travaille dans le 20e
tu vois et
elle m'a aidé tu sais de ouf et à la fin
bah j'ai eu un entretien avec avec le le
directeur d'un lycée bac provente et je
suis rentré dedans et cresendo il a
quiit mon profil mon potentiel mais
c'est pour t'expliquer que s'il avait
pas eu feu vert j'aurais j'aurais
peut-être vu le côté négatif de la vie
l'économie parallèle tu vois je pas te
faire de dessin tuis ils ont ce rôle un
peu d'éponge écouter tu vois parce
qu'ils sont dans la pédagogie à fond tu
vois ils sont là pour les jeunes et pas
que pour les jeunes en feu vert ils sont
là pour tout ce qui est papera si une
maman ne parle pas forcément français ou
quoi que ce soit tu vois ils sont là
vraiment pour pour aider mais ils te
donneront jamais la chose dans ta bouche
tout cru et là il est là le le petit
bein tu vois parce qu' en a beaucoup qui
pensent que tu veux un feu vert je veux
du travail ok vas-y tiens
non ils vont pas te donner ils vont voir
si tu es motivé tu vas aller avec il
vont te montrer comment faire et ça il
faut avoir une motivation en soi tuis il
faut se faire
combat
ça fait 12 ans que je suis sur sur ce
quartier là là ça je vais sur la 13e
année mais il me le disent aujourd'hui
les anciens que toi tu es toujours là Mo
tu te dis tu t'es pas trompé parce que
il y a des moments difficiles après tu
tu tu peux devenir aussi un petit peu le
celui qui porte un petit peu toute la
responsabilité de le
frustration
certains pour moi el c'est comme un
grand frère parce que depuis tout petit
je l'ai je le connais depuis je sais que
c'est quelqu'un j'ai confiance en lui il
a confiance en moi et franchement ouais
ça ça peut que être positif ça peut que
être positif il me voyz traîner un peu
il était là vas-y va à l'école qu'est-ce
que tu fais ici mais franchement je l'en
veux pas je peux que le remercier au
jour d'aujourd'hui j'ai mon bac j'ai
j'ai le diplôme que que ma mère
attendait tempant et franchement je peux
que le remercier quand ta mère elle va
travailler tous les jours qu'elle est
toute seule qu'elle travaille qu'elle te
même quand tu as une basket trouée elle
va te l'acheter tu vois ce que je veux
dire franchement
tu tu tu au jour d'aujourd'hui je peux
que remercier ma mère je peux que
remercier ma mère parce que sans elle je
serai pas ce que je suis aujourd'hui
sans elle je serai pas et franchement
c'est c'est compliqué c'est vrai que ça
é compliqué de l'avir d'aller travailler
de mais moi aussi j'essaie de travailler
pour pour que mes enfants ils soient au
maximum pour que pour que mes
descendants comme on dit il soi ils soi
au top n on est là on est en bas tous
les jours on voit tous les jours la même
chose on connait tous les jours on voit
tout le temps la même chose mais il nous
fait découvrir les environs jeis pas moi
chez moi çae pas ça une activité cing en
famille et tout ma mère elle a d'autres
chat fouetté en
vrai on a fait du vélo on a fait du du
du du kayak TR truc et qui trop de trucs
trop de trucs j'ai fait du e j'ai fait
trop de trucs trop d'activités j'ai fait
du painball j'ai fait du karting j'ai
fait j'ai trop fait truc là là au jour
d'aujourd'hui je suis animateur de base
il m'a trouvé juste un truc pour juste
pour avoir un peu d'argent euh histoire
d'avoir un peu d'argent de poche grâce à
auouraujourd'hui ben ils ont kiffé mon
travail ils m'ont il m ils m'ont donné
plusieurs respons abilité ça dire je
gagne même plus le même salaire que je
gagnais au
début en plus m acheté de la
viande
maig mon frère sûr tu es par il arrive
de Turquie lu Lou et tout
ah parfa VO là là attention c'est gênant
là un petit cadeau de B écoute merci
beaucoup merci je peux montrer un petit
peu voilà voilà il est parti en vacances
il m'a ramené un petit cadeau voilà je
l'ouvrirai tranquillement tu l'ch
che c'est plutôt au collège où ça a
commencé
c'est souvent au collège à l'adolescence
on veut s'affirmer donc là on rencontre
des gens on se fait tous influencer par
les plus grands qui sont modèle et au
quartier bah à l'époque en tout cas les
modèles qu'on voyait c'était plutôt les
les grands avec des belles voitures
c'était plutôt ça et puis après on
rencontre on a une bande tout le monde
se voilà j'ai suivi j'ai suivi j'ai
suivi mon mes copains en fait c'est ça
et puis après au quartier bah ça
continue on commence à vendre des un peu
cheat voilà et puis voilà l'influence
c'est très important ils m'ont influencé
c'est pas vrai
il pas lui elle est arrivé au moment où
on commencait av des gros problèmes
arriv au moment où
il ce que j'ai adoré à l'époque che feu
vert c'est le fait qu' il porte pas de
jugement donc je me rappelle je les
avais rencontré ils étaient TR il y en a
TR qui m'ont marqué avec qui on a
beaucoup échangé qui nous écout
énormément parce que sonans jugement je
me rappelle j'avais intégré une école
àcé technique à dorient B en tout cas
dans 11e voilà et c'était grâce à
Nassera en plus elle m'a dit on était là
si j'arrive avec des numéros et j'ose
pas appeler parce que c'était une école
dans 11e et moi pour moi l' 11e carichi
j'ai allais que la nuit la serra elle
appppelle je sais pas comment elle a
fait elle a réussi à convaincre la
directrice un rendez-vous elle me dit
vas-y comment ça vas-y vas-y c'est bon
t'inquiète pas elle appelle j'ai mon
rendez-vous j'y vais et puis bam ça va
ma' tier je sais pas il voit que notre
projet on y tient à cœur ils vont nous
aider ils vont pas nous lâcher c'est ça
le truc il nous lâche pas et même quand
on a envie de lâcher ils sont là il dit
NON NON lâche pas moi j'ai confiance en
toi rien que le fait de dire j'ai
confiance en toi c'est voilà en tout cas
moi pour ma part c'est ce qui m'ont
apporté le fait d'avoir que de fait de
savoir que moi aussi je pouvais le faire
voilà elle a fait partie de ma vie elle
m'a
aidé et surtout aujourd'hui comme je dis
je suis un ingénieur automaticien et
c'est
elle c'est ma deuxème maman ça veut dire
que un jour je me je je me souviens on
était je crois que on était dans ma
voiture ou dans sa voiture j'ai dit j'ai
ma maman chez moi j'ai ma maman j'ai ma
maman dehors on dit c'est qui je dis
c'est toi quand c'est pas elle qui me
prend la tête c'est toi qui me prends la
tête ouais en fait je pourrais pas
expliquer
c'est je sais pas j'ai j'ai on ressent
les choses je voyais beaucoup de
sincérité chez elle et le fait qu'elle
soit aussi sensible à l'art je crois que
c'est ça qui a fait que et je pense que
comme ils ont pris leur travail au
sérieux nous aussi on les a pris au
sérieux très vite et oui ça a sauvé
beaucoup de personnes et même si parfois
il y avait il pouvait avoir un lapse de
temps où on se voit pas mais on avait
toujours une pensée pour feu vert et je
pense que indirectement hein c'estes ces
éducateurs ces sorciers là indirectement
il nous ont ils nous ont donné ce truc
là en nous qui on va dire on a envie
d'aider les plus jeunes
automatiquement là là ce qui va se
passer c'est que là c'est le dernier
artiste je sais pas si vous le
connaissez
je peux dire une phrase pensez beaucoup
à la
vie sans ça tu es
rien tiens allez là ça a filmé là
tuenvoies tes
enfants
mais
moi